The final step in your
custom view creation
is adding interactivity.
You can listen for user input events
including key presses,
trackball movement,
and most importantly,
screen touch events.
All by overriding the
corresponding event handlers.
Android supports tracking of
up to 11 individual contact points
in what we like to call,
jazzhands mode
which enables you
to complete
complex, multi-finger
interaction models.
Now, there's really no interaction
required for a wind gauge,
but you can find out more
about handling input events
by checking the motion event docs
or the developer guide
describing how to create your own,
fully interactive custom views,
both from the instruction notes below.
Now, be careful not to let this
new found power go to your head.
By definition, your users
will have never encountered
your brand spanking new control.
So learning how to use it
is going to add friction
to the use of your app.
At the very least, it should behave
consistently with the rest of the system
and you should avoid creating
your own versions of system controls.
If it looks kind of like a button
and works kind of like a button,
you should probably
just go ahead and use a button.
But I think this non sequitur
has gone on long enough.